[موسيقى]
ينتقدوا ان المحكمه خضعت لضغوط قويه جدا
هذه الضغوط اثرت على صيغه القرار النهائي
للمحكمه
تحرك كثيرا لتقوم المحكمه بواجباتها طوال
اجراءات المحاكمات ولكن حدثت ضغوط كثيره
وهو ما ادى الى صدور
مختلفين عن المحكمه
ضغوطات للشطب اسماء المسؤولين السوريين
المتورطين طبعا
المسؤولين السوريين وانت تحملين الاثنين
او كما اعتقدت القياده الفرنسيه
انا
الاغتيال هو جريمه وان اغتيال شخص مثل
رئيس الحريري او رئيس الحكومه الحريري
يشكل جريمه
اذا ما كان العالم مقتنعا فعلا ولديه
معلومات بانهم تورطوا في الاغتيال
ولهذا السبب العلاقات مع سوريا معقده الى
هذا الحد تحديدا من اراد ان يحمي النظام
السوري القيادات على الاقل التي تورطت
مصر
اعتقد انه النظام نفسه